well i'm just wondering if it is the
last season
is there room would you return for the
fans to appease us
in some capacity i just feel like that's
a hard question to answer because
nobody's asked me to come back
i can't i can't answer that
all i'll say is that i love that i love
my family over there and so i would
never say no
to the possibility but you know
it's it hasn't presented itself well
sarah it's so good to see you
i wish it was in person but it's good to
see you over zoom at least
see you too katie i did see that you
were posting about your kids
doing the greatest showman so i just
want to know how that actually
came about and how do you feel having
your kids kind of follow in your
asking footsteps um
well okay so we we started doing these
backyard movie nights where the
families sat and pods six feet apart and
you know we just would do this kind of
community building thing and one of the
movies we watched was the greatest
showman with all the neighborhood kids
they became completely obsessed and
started rehearsing
in the yard every evening after dinner
and
my son for weeks this was for like three
weeks this is months ago
for three weeks my son is like we're
doing the greatest showman we're doing
it on halloween
it's going to be a full production the
whole show and i'm like okay great sure
he's got a lot of dreams this kid like
so yeah and the
year award for doing all of this well
look i have been unemployed
since january and i
have so much artistic energy that
i needed to put it somewhere so this
was this was where i got to put it it
became it's becau it like activated me
on
all cylinders so it was a gift to me how
are you as a director
well i got to i mean the great thing is
that i i directed
a web series for grey's anatomy my final
year on the show
and so i got to train that whole season
so when you're working with seven
children between the ages of
four and ten they melt after one
and none of they're not they're kids
they're not professional actors you know
they're not like used to being on sets
this is completely new for them
so i had you know an hour before
everybody fell apart so i would have to
shoot like
a four-page scene in one hour with seven
kids so i
and i used the training that i had
working on grays
to really know what my shot list was
going to be to keep it as simple as
possible and we shot in front of a big
green screen so
when i edit it together i got to put
them in all these crazy locations
you know i can't talk to you without
talking a little bit about bray's
anatomy
well this didn't go according to plan
there was sort of big news this week
because ellen pompeo said this could be
the last season
oh really of grey's anatomy so
i'm just wondering if it is the last
season
is there room would you return for the
fans to appease us
in some capacity i just feel like that's
a hard question to answer because
nobody's asked me to come back
i can't i can't answer
that all i'll say is that i love that i
love my family over there and so i would
never say no
um to the possibility but you know
it's it hasn't presented itself to me
yeah you did get a lot of fans
excited and feeling nostalgic a few
weeks ago
oh yes of you and jessie williams
i mean do you think
obviously i know they haven't asked you
yet but is there more jprol
potentially to tell you are gonna have
to ask the writers
i don't know i can't answer any of that
i don't know well do you think that
their ending is their real ending like
do you think they're
like baby harriet deserves justice
i've said this so many times if it were
if it had been up to me
they would have been endgame like it
that if it were up to me but you know
it's not up to me
jessica capshaw said people still think
she's on grace because now it's
streaming and people
yeah it is the same thing for you yeah i
have no idea
oh yeah oh yeah for sure like i love you
on that show
i like that thank you oh that happens
all the time that happens all the time
i mean not now that we wear masks and no
one can recognize us anywhere we go
but um but yeah you know what i love
about that
is i love that i will always be on grace
like you know what i mean like it just
it's always going to be a part of my
life
um it's always going to be a really
important
piece of my career and uh
and a really beautiful point of
reference for fans
and i love i love that i love that my
character brought
so much laughter and and joy and tears
and drama and made people
think and wrestle with big questions
like and knowing
that you know especially during this
pandemic i'm on cameo
which i've loved doing because it's
so many young girls like so many 13
14 and so many of them are are inspired
to go into the medical profession and so
many of them
started watching during the pandemic and
have like watched the entire series four
times and like
you that's like you know i get i get the
the request from a parent saying she has
been watching this
every day since the beginning of the
pandemic and and it's it's just
it's beautiful it's beautiful to to have
had the chance for the years that i got
to be on that show to participate in
something
that's so well loved so far reaching and
so evergreen
yeah you know it's it's a privilege it's
it really is
i love that my heart feels so happy
right now um
will you let your kids watch the show or
have they watched i mean eventually
it's just a little too grown up for them
they're they're and yeah they
my son can't handle a drop of blood a
drop
so i don't think that would work out
he can't look at blood and he can't see
mom kissing in homework movies
certainly not you're just amazing you're
so wonderful
i feel like you're just the best oh
katie
oh you are i always feel so happy after
i talk to you and i'm like
something um but you are wonderful this
movie was so good so i'm so excited it's
such a treat i can't wait for people to
see it
i didn't expect to bump into you again
i'm sorry to disappoint
did you actually learn to play violin i
i i tr i had a one hour
session every single day for my entire
christmas break because
the when we went that we went back to
bucharest to shoot all the stuff
interior stuff
so that's all my violin playing was
happening i had an
hour-long session with the composer who
also plays the violin
in the movie uh you know for the
soundtrack and um
she worked with me for an hour every
single day and i practiced for three
hours every single day so i was
practicing for three hours plus working
with her for an hour
every day of my christmas break it was
two so two and a half solid weeks
leading up to when we left to go to
bucharest
so i learned i memorized exactly
what string i needed to be up on for
every single note
and what whether i was going a bowing up
or bowing down
and then obviously this hand was like i
just knew kind of what part of the
of the bar it needed to be on that's not
even the right one
because whatever but it doesn't matter
um but even just getting
the the motion correct so that you're
not
bouncing your string all over it was so
hard i have never been more stressed out
about anything i've had to do for any
acting job in my life
can you play the violin now like could
you play no no no i don't i don't well i
i by the end of it i would hit a note or
two that were correct
but i you know i
if i really wanted to i could probably
learn but it is
hard so hard just to learn how to fake
it
i just was really committed i was like
anybody who plays any music
if i don't look like i know what i'm
doing it'll take them right out of the
movie and i don't want anyone to be
taken out of the movie
so freaking professional to me that's
why i was like did you actually learn to
do that
and i had a double so when you're
looking at me from behind that was my
double playing
but the thing about playing violin is
when they're on a close-up like you
could play piano down here and like
jam and you don't see anything but when
you're here it's right next to your face
like your bow is right next to your face
so i had to look
like i knew what i was doing for all the
moments that they came in
tight on me so i learned all of the
songs wow i mean
not learned learned like you wouldn't
want to listen to me play it because
they're not the right notes but
going in the right direction anyway why
your parents do sound great
they have this saying that love is
learning the song in someone's heart and
singing it
when they need it most well i like that
i think that's right the best parts
about doing hallmark movies
is now that i've talked to so many
different actors who have done these
it's like you actually get to go and
have the experience of a lifetime like
you get to go to these amazing places
you do get to bring your loved ones
the movies are just so joyous and
nice and magical will you watch this
movie when it premieres
with the family like do the kids get
excited to watch these movies
my son is super anti-romance
what no
super anti-wrong he's like there's if
there's any kissing i'm out
like i'm not watching it at all like not
at all um i my daughter
has seen both of my christmas movies
that have done before
um so they'll they'll watch i mean he'll
we'll
make him watch and he'll watch but he'll
be like
he's like mom where are the spaceships
and the blasters and the spies
you have a lot to celebrate though
because you have a new show that you are
going to go film
so i want to hear all about it what is
this show
who do you play yes
um so it's called cruel summer and it's
going to be on freeform
um and so i'm i'm playing a character
named cindy turner
um the show focuses on these two teenage
girls
jeanette and kate and i play jeanette's
mom
and it takes place uh on
on one day in 1993 94 and 95
and in each of these years things have
changed dramatically for both of these
girls
and each episode you flip back and forth
between jeanette's perspective and then
kate's perspective
and you and it's a thriller so you're
trying to figure out
they [ __ ] things shift dramatically and
and you and you get that in the first
like five seconds of the pilot
and you're like how what you know and so
the whole season is trying to unpack
all of this stuff like why what happened
that
led these two girls into these three
completely different
planes of existence and and all the
while you're learning i mean it's
it's beautifully written and constructed
because you're you're diving into family
dynamics and
and coming of age stuff and relational
dynamics and
so i play i play jeanette's mom
um who has a ton of stuff thrown at her
as
all these things are happening to her
[Music]
daughter